donc je suis rentré par hasard dans le
monde de la finance internationale
j'étais parti apprendre l'anglais à
bristol en angleterre et là il ya une
personne une femme qui m'a proposé
d'aller travailler à jersey pour un gros
cabinet d'avocats donc à l'époque pour
moi paradis fiscal c'était un endroit
qui me paraissait plein de secrets donc
j'ai accepté intuitivement je voulais
découvrir ce qu'il y avait là-bas non
gex et qu'est-ce que j'ai découvert
tellement de choses en fait qu' il y
avait tout simplement mais ça tout le
monde le sait une impunité incroyable et
en fait j'ai vu que les paradis fiscaux
étaient utilisés de façon très important
par les hauts fonctionnaires français
par des politiques français par l'état
français et sans compter les
multinationales évidemment que c'est
utilisé pour plein de raisons
différentes pour des rétrocommissions
pour de la fraude fiscale évidemment
pour faire des délits d'initiés pour
organiser des liquidations frauduleuse
d'entreprise de sites industriels qui
sont pourtant excédentaires dont qui
sait utiliser vraiment c'est une plate
forme utilisée pour faire 36 enfin dix
mille coup si vous voulez pour les gens
les plus puissants alors durant ces cinq
années pour lesquelles j'ai travaillé
dans la finance offshore et pour la dgse
donc je passais mon temps à collecter de
l'information tant à mon travail donc le
plus gros cabinet de lille qui est
mourrant qu'est vraiment un énorme usine
à gaz et que six employés mais aussi en
permanence en dehors
je côtoyais je passais mon temps à
côtoyer les différents réseaux réseau
d'avocats d'expert comptable d'auditeurs
il faut savoir que le milieu et lien les
gens en soirée vous vous dise énormément
de choses vous parlent de leurs clients
vous parle de toutes ces choses là
donc moi je collecter toutes les
informations que je donnais ensuite à
mon officier traitant de la dgse
j'allais voir de façon très régulière à
paris qui me débriefait et
et ensuite il allait vérifier certains
éléments en un camp directement les
serveurs des cabinets d'avocats ou des
banques
alors oui les désillusions vis-à-vis la
dgse c'était demeurant enfin plus
vis-à-vis de l'état parce que finalement
le 10g ce n'est qu'un brad de l'état
c'était de me rendre compte que les
informations que je collectais n'allait
pas pour pour le premier concitoyens ce
qui à l'origine alors peut-être
naïvement était mon objectif mais était
ensuite délivré à d'autres
multinationales françaises pour qu'elles
soient entre guillemets plus
compétitives ou et des milliardaires
français donc en fait
de fait mon travail avec la dg se
permettait aux riches des plus riches
et ça c'était quelque chose que je
pouvais pas accepter donc jeu en fin
2011 début 2012 j'ai arrêté de
travailler avec la dgse et de la finance
pour aider directement les groupes de
salariés et des syndicats
en revenant en france alors la sécurité
je fais je suis juste vigilant je suis
attention et je considère justement que
plus je suis à la lumière et que je
travaille que la presse moins il ya de
risque alors je dis pas qu'il ya pas de
risque de procès ça n'y a pas de
problème c'est des procès
je verrai le moment venu mais en terme
de sécurité il faut le but c'est d'être
à la lumière